[Music]
we have some real problems in this
country that are deep and structural
that have to be confronted with the
truth of who we are
i invite each and every one of you
listen to these different voices
have the courage to say hmm
let me see what this wrestling with
white supremacy and black love is all
about
in this class we are going to be
focusing on these powerful issues
together you will learn how slavery and
anti-blackness is foundational to nearly
every american institution in modern
life even if we refuse to see it
you may hear things that you find hard
to believe they are a testament to parts
of our history that we've dismissed the
story that you can tell about this
country about it being a land of
equality and opportunity who gave
america that we gave america that there
has been this unbroken history of
struggle for liberation for hundreds of
years
black people
managed to create beauty in the very
process of fighting structural racism
black love is that thing that makes you
believe in american democracy even when
american democracy hasn't believed in us
one of our jobs is to try to make there
be as little racism as possible
a more important job is to see where the
racism is and think about ways that we
can get past it race is a fiction
racism is real what do we do with that
and it's only in having that
understanding of what built the country
that we're in that we can dismantle the
parts of our country that don't live up
to its highest ideals
[Music]
i'm john mcwater i'm cherylin eifel i'm
jelani cobb nicole hannah jones kimberly
williams crenshaw cornell west i'm
angela davis and this is masterclass
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you